en el vídeo sobre la bomba sodio potasio
hablamos de cómo ésta ayuda a la célula
a establecer su potencial de membrana en
reposo y lo logra al bombear activamente
123 iones de sodio hacia el exterior por
cada uno dos iones de potasio que bombea
hacia el interior celular y esta
proporción por sí misma
esta proporción de 3 a 2 por sí sola no
establece por completo el potencial de
membrana en reposo pero los iones de
potasio también se difunden a favor de
su gradiente de concentración van del
interior al exterior y claro hay una
fuerza que está en equilibrio con el
gradiente de concentración es decir un
factor que está en equilibrio y este es
la carga como el exterior celular es más
positivo que el interior celular
entonces un guión con carga positiva
como este de aquí en este caso los iones
de potasio no querrán salir de la célula
debido
es más positivo aquí en el exterior que
aquí abajo y de hecho querrán regresar
pero su gradiente de concentración hace
que sean bombeadas hacia fuera por este
canal que tengo aquí entonces tendremos
que habrá un equilibrio entre estas
fuerzas comenzarán a difundirse pero no
habrá la misma concentración en ambos ya
que la carga mantendrá aquí en el
interior a estos iones pero qué hay de
los iones de sodio los iones de sodio si
te das cuenta se encuentran en mayor
proporción aquí en el exterior y eso
hace que esto se vuelva más positivo que
los que tenemos aquí en el interior si
se dejará que los iones de sodio se
movían libremente es decir si no
existiera esta membrana ellos
naturalmente se movería a favor de su
gradiente de concentración y si te das
cuenta su gradiente de concentración es
aquí tenemos una menor concentración
menor concentración mientras que aquí
tenemos una mayor concentración mayor
concentración entonces si no existiera
esta membrana ellos se moverían de donde
hay mayor concentración hacia donde hay
menor concentración y también si no
existiera membrana y como ya mencionamos
el exterior es más positivo es más
positivo que bueno el interior déjenme
poner aquí uno
para representar que es menos positivo o
podríamos decir que hay una diferencia
de potencial entre esto el exterior y el
interior
entonces los guiones con carga positiva
como el sodio se van a querer mover al
interior debido a su carga por lo tanto
hay dos razones por las cuales los iones
de sodio querrán ir del exterior al
interior de la membrana celular el
primero es su gradiente de concentración
y el segundo su carga su potencial
eléctrico que hace que estos iones que
han alejado de las otras cargas
positivas y bueno justo esta motivación
combinada que hace que los iones de
sodio quieran ir en esta dirección lo
llamamos un gradiente electroquímico un
gradiente
diente
electroquímico
aquí
único
y aunque ya lo dije lo voy a decir de
nuevo el gradiente electroquímico es la
combinación del gradiente eléctrico con
bueno con el gradiente químico por el
gradiente químico vamos a entender que
los iones que mueve de aquí del exterior
al interior debido a que hay una mayor
concentración en el exterior que en el
interior entonces tendríamos un flujo
neto a favor de su gradiente de
concentración y ahora si piensas en el
potencial eléctrico recuerda que es más
positivo de este lado que de este otro
lado entonces los iones positivos
querrán ir al interior de la célula
entonces puedes ver este gradiente como
una fuente de energía potencial y esto
es muy importante las células
de hecho utilizan este gradiente el
gradiente electroquímico del sodio es
una fuente de energía y ahora bien
digamos que esta de aquí
una proteína y le voy a poner un nombre
voy a decir que ésta se llama se
importador sí
este es importador lo que hace es que
utiliza el potencial electroquímico de
un guión en este caso los iones de sodio
y utiliza el hecho de que el sodio
quiere atravesar a como de lugar
esta membrana es decir estos aquí
quieren meterse justo por acá y utilizan
esa energía como una cascada que mueve a
un molino de agua
imagínate agua cayendo en una cascada y
esta cascada puede activar una turbina o
un molino de agua que hace que esto
salga que esto salga ahora bien utiliza
la energía del sodio que se mueve a
favor de su gradiente electroquímico
recuerda eso quiere decir que quiere ir
en esta dirección por dos razones por su
concentración y por su potencial
eléctrico o más bien por su carga
electrostática utilizan esta energía
para transportar otras cosas como y es
importador más famoso que utiliza el
sodio es es importador de luz
y esto de aquí es la glucosa que va a
viajar junto con el sodio aquí por el
importador y justo la glucosa es
transportada en contra de su gradiente
de concentración
entonces si tú vas a transportar algo en
contra de su gradiente de concentración
necesitas utilizar el transporte activo
déjame ser claro con el gradiente de
concentración de la glucosa observan que
se ve así aquí tengo este gradiente de
concentración porque aquí tengo una
mayor concentración de glucosa y aquí
una menor concentración de glucosa pero
la célula no quiere gastar su glucosa
quiero obtener tanta glucosa como sea
posible entonces tendrá que utilizar el
transporte activo para transportarla en
contra de su gradiente de concentración
para transportarla justo en esta
dirección es decir ir en contra del
gradiente de concentración
la glucosa y esa va a ser la fuente de
energía que van a obtener del potencial
almacenado que forman el gradiente
electroquímico del sodio entonces este
tipo de transporte activo donde se
utiliza la energía almacenada que se
obtuvo a partir de otro transporte
activo en este caso la bomba sodio
potasio lo llamamos un transporte activo
secundario así que lo que está
sucediendo aquí este es importador de
sodio glucosa va a utilizar este
transporte activo secundario estamos
hablando de un transporte transporte
activo
de un secundario
dario okay utiliza la energía almacenada
por el gradiente electroquímico de una
molécula utiliza esta energía para
lograr el transporte activo de otra
molécula por ejemplo la glucosa
moviéndose en contra de su gradiente de
concentración